Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
El cuerpo se transforma en una prisión.
El pasado, el presente y el futuro
existen como una fuerza única.
Una oscilación sin gravedad
se cierne a una altura espeluznante.
Los contornos de las personas
y las cosas se disuelven.
Numerosos poetas y escritores
han intentado describir
la experiencia del ataque de pánico:
una sensación tan abrumadora,
que mucha gente la confunde
con un infarto, un ACV
u otra crisis posiblemente fatal.
Si bien el ataque de pánico
no provoca heridas físicas perdurables,
el miedo a tener otro ataque
puede limitar el día a día de una persona
y causar más ataques de pánico.
Hay estudios que indican
que casi un tercio de nosotros
experimentará un ataque de pánico
al menos una vez en la vida.
Ya sea tu primer ataque o el centésimo,
o que estés presenciando
el ataque de otra persona,
todos preferirían evitar la experiencia.
Incluso aprender al respecto
puede resultar incómodo, pero es necesario
pues el primer paso para prevenir
los ataques de pánico es entenderlos.
En esencia, un ataque de pánico
es una reacción extrema
a la respuesta fisiológica
normal del organismo
frente a la percepción de peligro.
Esta respuesta comienza en la amígdala,
la región cerebral asociada
con el procesamiento del miedo.
Cuando la amígdala percibe peligro,
estimula el sistema nervioso simpático,
que desencadena
la liberación de adrenalina.
La adrenalina aumenta
el pulso cardíaco y la respiración
para que la sangre y el oxígeno lleguen
a los músculos de brazos y piernas.
También se envía más oxígeno al cerebro,
para volverlo más alerta y ágil.
Durante un ataque de pánico,
esta respuesta se exacerba
más allá de lo que sería útil
en una situación de peligro.
Esto produce un pulso cardíaco acelerado,
respiración dificultosa
o hiperventilación.
Los cambios en el torrente sanguíneo
producen mareos
y entumecimiento en manos y pies.
El momento más intenso de
un ataque de pánico suele ser a los 10'.
Entonces, la corteza prefrontal
releva a la amígdala y estimula
el sistema nervioso parasimpático.
Así se desencadena la producción
de una hormona llamada acetilcolina
que disminuye el ritmo cardíaco
y gradualmente detiene
el ataque de pánico.
En un ataque de pánico,
la percepción de peligro del organismo
es suficiente para desencadenar
la respuesta que tendríamos
ante una amenaza real.
No sabemos exactamente
por qué sucede esto,
pero a veces algunos indicios
del entorno nos recuerdan
una experiencia traumática del pasado
que puede causar un ataque de pánico.
El ataque de pánico puede ser
parte de los trastornos de la ansiedad
como el TEPT,
el trastorno de ansiedad social, el TOC
y el trastorno de ansiedad generalizada.
Los ataques de pánico recurrentes,
las preocupaciones por nuevos ataques
y los cambios de comportamiento
para evitar estos ataques
pueden conducir a un diagnóstico
de trastorno de pánico.
Los principales tratamientos
para el trastorno de pánico
son antidepresivos
y la terapia cognitiva conductual,
o TCC.
Ambos tienen una tasa de respuesta
de alrededor de un 40 %.
Aunque un paciente que responde
a uno podría no responder al otro.
Sin embargo, los antidepresivos
producen algunos efectos secundarios,
y el 50 % de los pacientes sufren
una recaída cuando dejan de tomarlos.
La TCC, por su parte, dura más
y solamente el 20 % tiene recaídas.
El objetivo de la TCC,
en el caso de estos pacientes,
es ayudarlos a aprender
y poner en práctica
mecanismos puntuales
para ejercer control físico y mental
sobre las sensaciones y pensamientos
asociados al ataque de pánico.
La TCC inicia con la explicación
de las causas fisiológicas
del ataque de pánico.
Incluye ejercicios
musculares de respiración
diseñados para ayudar a las personas
a controlar de forma consciente
los patrones de respiración.
Luego, se enseña
la reestructuración cognitiva,
que implica identificar y cambiar
los pensamientos
que son comunes durante un ataque
—pensar que se te cortará la respiración,
que tendrás un infarto o que morirás—
y reemplazarlos
con pensamientos más realistas.
El siguiente paso del tratamiento
es la exposición
a las sensaciones corporales
y a las situaciones que comúnmente
desencadenarían un ataque de pánico.
El propósito es cambiar la creencia,
a través de la experiencia,
de que estas sensaciones
y situaciones son peligrosas.
Incluso tras la TCC,
no es sencillo realizar estas tareas
al momento de sufrir un ataque.
Pero con práctica, estas estrategias
pueden prevenir, aminorar los ataques
y, finalmente, reducir el control
del pánico sobre la vida de una persona.
Más allá de las terapias formales,
muchos pacientes encuentran alivio
en la misma creencia
que la TCC busca inculcar:
el miedo no puede lastimarte,
pero aferrarte a él aumenta el pánico.
Incluso si jamás has tenido
un ataque de pánico,
entender de qué se trata
te ayudará a reconocerlo en ti mismo
o en otras personas.
Y reconocerlo es el primer paso
hacia su prevención.